hey I can love you did I ever tell you
how much I love you
it's like I said it don't run I love you
you are the sad thing is I don't say it
enough
I don't express it enough look at this
face this is the face of a man who wants
you to know that you are you all you
know what I got there problem is I've
been love is a sign of weakness and oh
stop showing the world how much you love
your woman is a sign of sexy women
President Obama be without Michelle
lonely
we're with the Cosby's be without Claire
Sana's father was funny man be without
Mary Jane beating the [ __ ] out of his
dirt somewhere along the lines of being
together
I forgot that loving you isn't about my
insecurities it's about me yeah baby
let's go home right now give me a bottle
of baby oil a children's book and some
loofah Vandross and how rocky oh you are
better fact you don't even need to touch
me
using lay down and let me do the work is
laid-back you punk that [ __ ] in neutral
we wake up Alexis [ __ ] I love you like a
David sell love cake and I love cake one
time I saw somebody drop a baby and a
piece of cake at the same time like this
one know what I did I walk come on slap
that baby when I say that goddamn cake
you know what I'm saying is if you and a
double cheeseburger almost no one in it
that's right if you want a double
cheeseburger what hanging off the cliff
I'd let that cheeseburger fall to its
toll
when you go really you hungry oh that's
right girl I will cook for you tonight
and any other night you feel like you
don't want to Wow because my baby mice
are and she needs to know that she is
appreciated that's right they caught me
shed Boyard
Deez Nuts do you have any idea how you
make me feel when you come around again
butterflies in my stomach and I can't
spit girl you still fight every time you
come around out here speechless so I
know sign language just so I can do this
girl you know how much I love you if you
don't want to take off your shoes in my
ancient house you don't have to all [ __ ]
you don't wanna use chopsticks go that's
fine uniform girl I don't give up you a
vegetarian you want me to be one too
well guess what that's where I draw the
line you need to get them Dell Vaz the
net okay baby
I love you so much I'll go to the jet
for you girl high cholesterol heart
disease and a heart attack can't get me
to go to the gym but I'll curl the [ __ ]
out of that six pound dumbbell for you
oh ma look I know I haven't been the
best friend I can be now sugar nipples
my Turkish delight my Asian persuasion
my Ugandan princess my Persian clean my
tickle nipple my little my little my
little booty crumbles but you know how
they say if you really love somebody you
should let them go that dumb [ __ ] is
stupidest follow better myself in order
to preserve this love that we have and
you know what I love you time I pull up
come up like that she come
like hey hello I can like you really
don't know what I'm about to jump out
per se